okay so i'm gonna
clear the clear it give him some weight
what's he gonna do he don't posture up
that's my step
so hold down the postures up
two the two are go the two are going he
goes
up following him boom
[Music]
okay let's go so passive
okay so when he goes to that grip
i have to disarm it
okay here
[Music]
and clear the line clear the line get
away from
uh the rest of his body try to try
exposing the back
okay so he's not like this
he's pushing your hands let him push
your hand into the technique
okay let's try okay so when he's going
don't
don't leave him here
let his energy go boom down
attack his posture both okay and then
give him that fear so he doesn't he does
not want that
okay he has to uh deal with that
and make sure you have this so
that that's not there and it's not
supporting the
other leg the other single leg okay
so boom top we're going to take it down
and then around and in
let me go feed it down keep his head
down
and then decide control or pull it down
if it's someone's head you have to
protect then
over the top if it's not
keep it going tight
okay let's get there
so
okay so uh you have
this kind of i can go more passive if i
want
especially the guys pushing into me okay
so as he's trying to come in
you're gonna wanna you're gonna wanna do
the uh two lovers you're trying to come
in
if the guy bases out on you it is like
he's trying to figure out what to do
then uh you can attack the back left
the the back legs
let's have more of a yielding
[Music]
okay let's go so as i'm going here and
he's checking me out
i don't want to resist he does jiu-jitsu
so
he yielded and i'll yield and i'll go
right to my single leg
the motion
cover here shoulder
okay let's go